a cup of coffee in California could soon
come with a cancer warning mediation
begins today in a highly charged lawsuit
the Council for education and research
on toxics wants businesses to warn
consumers about a possible cancer risk
from coffee
that's right coffee the push for warning
stems from a natural chemical produced
when the coffee beans are roasted John
Blackstone explores why some think the
battle is way overblown coffee sellers
are steamed a lawsuit that's been
grinding on for years alleges no matter
how you make it your daily jolt of java
comes with a potential carcinogen
acrylamide that's the major reason
coffee turns brown bill Wriston part a
chemical engineer teaches the science of
coffee at UC davis as an expert witness
he testified that acrylamide forms
naturally as foods cooked at high
temperatures turn brown it's a major
reason to get this yummy brown stuff on
the outside of your steak when you chart
but in high doses acrylamide has been
found to cause cancer in mice that puts
it on a list of cancer-causing chemicals
that businesses in California are
required to alert consumers about thanks
to a law passed in 1986 so now under
California's Proposition 65 coffee shops
are being forced to post signs like this
trouble is in California right now
cancer seems to be brewing everywhere at
least it appears that way if you paying
the attention to these prop 65 warning
signs park your car in an indoor garage
and you're likely to find one at any
place that sells alcohol the writing's
on the wall it's posted at the happiest
place on earth and even outside CBS News
Los Angeles
Hastings law professor Marcia Cohen they
create in some people concern that
there's something lurking in places and
they don't know what it is but the
potential coffee warning may be
stretching the intention of the law
CBS contributor dr. David agus I believe
in transparency but at the same time
when you put a bold declaration X may
cause cancer when there isn't data to
that effect in humans to me it causes
panic rather than
form knowledge in a statement the
National Coffee Association told CBS
News
this lawsuit simply confuses consumers
and has the potential to make a mockery
of prop 65 cancer warnings at a time
when the public needs clear and accurate
information about health while thirteen
defendants including Gloria Jean's and
7-eleven have settled and agreed to put
up the signs Starbucks is still waging a
legal battle arguing that coffee has
benefits coffee and moderation has been
shown to potentially decrease the risk
of certain cancers and potentially to
have some heart benefit so these warning
signs maybe one coffee order that
Californians will have some trouble
swallowing for CBS this morning John
Blackstone San Francisco